[Music]
[Applause]
hello my name is hey Suz Trejo stand-up
comedian and I suck at golf according to
Malcolm Gladwell if you do anything for
10,000 hours you're considered a master
and I beg to differ
I'm really excited because today I get
to play with my dear friend Jay Larson
and we're gonna be playing and betting
strokes and all the proceeds go to our
dear friend Steve Simone's charity help
Steve help
[Music]
this is tea time with me hey sis tray oh
what a gorgeous day of golf we have
ahead of us at el christo Golf Course in
scenic Sylmar California is beautifully
crafted year round Municipal Golf Course
stretches over 4,000 493 yards of golf
with a par of 62 it's nestled right next
to La Mission college the course was
opened in 1977 and designed by Robert
Muir graves
it also features Kikuyu grass fairways
and immaculately tendon oh i annua
greens the signature hole is number 11
fisher downhill par 3 with beautiful
mountain views today is gonna be 74
degrees fahrenheit with 10% humidity
stay hydrated out there get that
camera I got 200 to that ravine well the
whole host 300 if I hit a 5-iron 180 I'm
short of that ravine I got 120 in you
know what I mean I think sometimes it's
better to like not think about what you
want to hit to your first shot but what
do you want a hit for your second if
it's a short or if you're like well I
love hitting 140 yards and it's 360 then
you're like all right what's your 220
Club then just hit that everyone always
wants a hit driver you know it's like a
like a you know what do you want a close
are you know golf courses they name like
the they name like the holes or let you
go over like you know Johnson's Brit you
think they name that Bridget like that
breath like I don't know man let's put a
little bridge there dude you gotta solve
riddles to get through that one it's
fine one straight
oh man
top town baby I mean the great thing for
playing for charity is that you're like
huh who gives a right I got you at
186 186 to the right dog leg all right
what's your 186 7 know yeah bro all day
yeah yeah you guys have to get his
reaction for another 20 bucks says you
put it in the ravine in the ravine yeah
I said I hope someone's keeping a tally
if I fall short it's no 20 right sure
stop it's not in there I told you it was
gonna be in the ravine no that made my
own ravine right yeah double or nothing
double or nothing all right I don't know
how much what do you think I have I mean
all right here we go it was a practice
swing yeah it's not in the ravine it's
trying to go like why would anyone ever
hit a driver in this hole
you're still 150 right here but now what
are you gonna do I gotta go a little
more ambitious wait this shot was
ambition yeah I'm going to three a
3-iron yeah so a 7-iron back there and
the three iron here
hey you got a gesture shot no yeah of
course okay the ravine get out of the
ravine you saw that it's out golf people
talk about it it's like an addiction but
as you can see you have a true addict
like he thinks there's a way out of this
and there isn't where drug acted like
dude everything's to be right here look
he's looking he's looking way up there
and where is it way back here no well
you're gonna hit from there
I'm gonna go driver now were you hitting
from there I mean I get it I got a
number it up but like it's gonna be
around like
this is my guess 123 get on good grass
all right perfect
people want to know what's he gonna do
going 9-iron you know what I think
you're gonna go into over here okay
to the right I'll do five on it I got
five on it
you gonna five into the Wild
West over there get down
heads up that's been lie that uh with uh
yeah that's uh I don't want to talk
about it hey Zeus okay all right so
you're probably like 130 130 it's easy
bro just golf it's all this is it's all
golf dude nice stay you know it's just
golf Jay that's a good ball I I did all
that to show you that dude you're right
man
there's just gold I'll see you up there
all right
see this ball there's an estate inside
this I'm gonna miss this they inside
this I'm gonna put a little cut spin on
it and try and get it right to the green
and roll back towards the hole so if I
can land it just past the shadow of that
tree I think oh this is bad dude whoa no
way oh wow sit Wow no way
you know what did just call it's just
golf remember that guys that sound I
love on that ball
in turn huh take that thinner thank you
I mean you're such a hex on me
no that was beautiful top light hex in
there oh he's not only playing top
flight he's playing refinished top
lights yeah these are like you can play
pool with okay let's hear yours yes
yours yeah this is this is dope you got
to get the only certified pre-owned top
fly balls aside for you what's the
warrant yet five strokes are better top
play ball on bouncy we're not on
hey Zeus keeps up his consistent play
with an expected 5 over par Jay manages
great recovery reminiscent of the great
John Daly and secures a bogey it might
be time for hey-zeus
to get some new balls turn get through
tree trimming season baby that's up
there somewhere Hayes's somebody's bird
nest I see it I think it got through
unless that's it right up there no way
[Laughter]
no you know whose ball listen it has the
ball played it got through you can have
the place where it live dude drop get up
ah how's your arm you got a good arm I
want to see you can get close over the
throw underhand her over however would
take you to get there me to kick dammit
oh you got me get over Oh No ah yeah you
got me uh now I'm gonna walk over there
yes you did yes you trained him and
stuff whenever I try to train them they
would leave you know but I was able to
catch him I used to put it like birdseed
inside my like door we had a little
balcony uh-huh and they would have come
in and start eating I closed the door
and I would have them and they'd be
flying around the apartment
everywhere my mom hated it really that's
so weird why would she hate that I don't
know it's get up nice all right let me
drain this par putt go go hit it hit it
ah ooh
Oh
ready same time one two hey Zeus is in
hot pursuit with a turkey well Jay can't
quite seal the deal and finishes with a
double bogey the heat is on when we say
this was one 38:30 downhill
beautiful shot we'll see
it's going right boys running the
you want to just take a drop there's a
drop zone right there well I hit a wedge
136 but downhill yeah it says drop zone
get out get out
dang it dude that trap is like concrete
it's cement in here carp pass one nice
gotta cut it go go get in there that's
you you wouldn't putt this no tiger
wouldn't put it you see the look on this
guy's face man come on babe bro
what if I just made this if you get it
within a clubs length any way around
I'll put 20 towards Steve Simone's fun
all right
done deal guess who's putting $20 toward
Steve someone's fund my home course this
old guy was teeing off and like
everybody would be there and this guy
tells his wife it's okay honey get it
over there you know that and he goes to
tee off and he tows it Shh right on the
head no right down Yeah right there on
the tee box do you hear the sound of
that thing get it get it yeah so the
parade right Hayes's finishes with a
whopping six over par while Jay wraps it
up with the beautiful three strokes
let's see how much more money hey Zeus
is giving to charity that's good see and
feel how the PGA guys feel huh yeah same
feel right yeah it's basically the same
thing you just can't cuss out loud yeah
and do it here freely it's all wrong
all right not too too bad no what what
what is this checking the wind dude you
got it you got it the extra tea do you
really play to the wind yeah I think
he's fly well before it didn't look like
much but then I was like stand there I'm
like I feel a little bit of something I
still think he's lying proof will be in
the pudding and the pudding let's see it
so what tree you're gonna have I'm not
you see that uh fault in wood pine yeah
that's gonna be short you're gonna be
with me baby
did the wind carry it over there yeah
that one really we came up once you get
into those you know up in certain you
see that video that's out I forget the
player but like he's at a guy's house
and he's in the front lawn he's a PGA
dude uh-huh
and he's like they have him chipping
over the house and in the back there's a
pool with a floating green on it all
right and he's hitting over and they got
his friend is there he's like hold on a
second hold on a second we're on
FaceTime he's gonna tell us and then he
hits it and then you hear everybody go
oh my god he was like you hit the green
he goes yeah well my name's on the bag
he's like I'm a pro like course I hit it
I'm gonna say he made it in I'm like
that's crazy but yeah you would expect a
guy like that to make it on the green
sure it was a floating green in a pool
like this big
he's practice that a million times
that's how they get that good yeah for
sure they don't go to the range Jay no
backyard trick shots man go get up there
and go get up there and get down it get
up oh it's hey that was the hello sit
I thought it would be a little smell is
the line make these four pars baby
good roll oh that's way too high that's
great give it another second there it is
boom hey thanks man you're the best -
thanks for coming out man
a respectable finish were our
competitors J with a bogey and hey Zeus
with a double bogey we're gonna look the
other way about that no-look shot at the
end so 120 bucks 120 bucks plus the
other ravine about 150 he's give 150
let's do 150 150 done deal
it's probably the last time you'll play
golf with me you're like hell no I'm
riding it fine never again I knew it I
had that one cool shot though which one
dude well we have to look through the
footage and stuff but well I mean the
good thing was there was a lot to pick
from yeah a lot of insert shots you know
a lot a lot of this you guys get that
[Music]
you